bienvenue dans pôle it mag spécial
élections municipales les français ont
la parole pendant toute cette campagne
et on va tenter de comprendre quelles
sont vos préoccupations au quotidien
avec des reportages sur le terrain vos
remarques et notre sondage sur nos
réseaux sociaux et puis bien sûr notre
débat aujourd'hui on va parler
immigration avec nos invités sur ce
plateau catherine vital de wenden
directrice de recherche au cnrs sur les
questions migratoires experte également
sur une mission au hcr face à vous jean
yves le gallou ancien député européen du
front national et essayiste ainsi que
danielle babin avocate spécialiste en
droit des étrangers
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
sur rt france
la france est devenue le premier pays de
l'union européenne en ce qui concerne le
nombre de demandeurs d'asile alors que
les entrées diminue en europe une
situation inédite depuis la crise
migratoire de 2015 la lutte contre
l'immigration le président français on a
fait une priorité à deux ans de
l'élection présidentielle à une question
qui préoccupe en tout cas certains
français en région paca notamment plus
d'un habitant sur quatre estime à qu'il
n'ya trop d'immigrés là où ils vivent
illustration à menton à la frontière
italienne sur la route des migrants
reportage signé nadège ad razak et lucas
tu as de nombreuses associations
viennent en aide à ces migrants
plusieurs d'entre elles en récemment
dénoncés et des violations des droits
des migrants en france
franck par exemple un migrant ghanéen de
32 ans qui a quitté son pays d'origine
il ya dix ans et qui cherchent plus que
tout soit rejoindre le territoire
français venus d'italie il a été
interpellé par les forces de l'ordre
françaises et il a passé toute la nuit
dans les locaux de la police aux
frontières de menton dans des conditions
difficiles il faisait très froid depuis
la nuit dernière où je me suis fait
arrêter je n'ai rien mangé
le problème c'est que la vie est très
dure en afrique
c'est pour ça que beaucoup de gens
partent moi par exemple je suis parti
pour essayer d'avoir une meilleure vie
je suis assez désemparé maintenant parce
que je n'ai aucun endroit où aller au
bout et la science et la durée de
rétention le fait qu'on m'explique pas
aux personnes qui ne soit pas entendu
lors d'un entretien personnalisé avec un
interprète qu'on ne leur permettent pas
de demander l'asile
lors de mes observations on a vu aussi
que deux des personnes disent des
migrants disent avoir demandé dit je
veux déposer une demande d'asile et on
leur a dit c'est par ici que ça se passe
quoi on les renvoie ici à menton deux
camps s'opposent d'un côté elle les
défenseurs des migrants de l'autre ceux
favorables à un retour vers leur pays
d'origine et à la fermeture des points
de passage
il ya déjà pas mal de misères en france
alors non je préfère que tu la france
les aide dans leur pays mais pas ici
la situation est difficile parce qu'il
ya plein de personnes ici en france qui
ont des besoins aussi
et comment faire pour contenter tout le
monde s'ils viennent chez nous ce que
chez eux ils sont malheureux et
certainement ils n'ont pas de quoi de
quoi vivre où il essaie d'avoir un
meilleur un meilleur avenir voit des
choses des enfants refoulé des enfants
qui sont mis dans des dans des
containers avec des personnes adultes
non ça ne s'est pas satisfait du taux de
la politique de refoulement qui a été
mise en place
l'immigration illégale a atteint son
plus bas niveau depuis 2013 quelque 139
me l'arrivée ont en effet été
enregistrés dans l'union européenne en
voilà pour ce reportage signé un adage
abderrazak et le cas tu as katrina est
vital de wenden on le voit il y a moins
d'entrées en europe en 2019 mais
néanmoins une explosion des demandes
d'asile en france
comment est-ce que vous expliquer alors
souvent ce sont des gens qui ont déjà
demandé l'asile dans un autre pays
européens notamment l'allemagne qui ont
été refusées comme réfugiés et qui au
bout d'un délai qui en général est
supérieur à 6 mois peuvent rouvrir leur
dossier dans un autre pays européen
sinon ils n'ont pas le droit dans le
système de dublin de demander l'asile
dans un autre pays tout de suite avec
des faits de nouveau donc c'est
considéré comme une nouvelle demande
d'asile mais de gens qui ont déjà été
déboutés sur un autre dossier si j'ose
dire et on verra ce qu'elle peut faire
une demande deux fois c'est ce que nos
jours maintenant parce que c'est là
qu'ils viennent d'allemagne
ils viennent galman donc les devants
l'asile en france ont les mêmes
finalement c'est j'en redemande l'asile
en france avec un dossier nouveau mais
ils ont été avoir fusé dans un autre
allemand d'accord pour la plupart des
cas parfois aussi peuvent ouvrir le
dossier mais c'est plus rare donc ce
sont des migrants finalement qui hier à
la rue du docteur danielle babin on l'a
vu le cas de ce migrant qui a été
intercepté par la police des frontières
à menton
comment ça se passe dans ces cas là vous
avez j'imagine défendu beaucoup de cas
similaires
ils sont arrêtés par la police et là on
voit il a été relâché
alors lorsque des migrants comme celui
là je pense qu'il est d'origine
ghanéenne sont arrivés en france
en réalité bon je pense qu'ils viennent
de leur pays d'origine tout de suite en
ils ont soit transité par un d'autres
pays européens ce peut être l'espagne
l'italie ça fait l'allemagne
en tout cas comme disait tout à l'heure
vous le 18 heures en fait le délai c'est
un an lorsqu'ils ont fait examiner leurs
dossiers en première en premier examen
dans un pays européen
il laisse passer un délai d'un an ils
ont la possibilité de devenir dans un
pays un deuxième pays qui à ce moment là
malheureusement peut leur opposer la le
règlement dublin
mais en réalité un an après le pays
comme la france aujourd'hui peut à
nouveau examiner leur demande
on ne peut plus leur donc à vous
dégoûter dans un pays est
systématiquement reconduits à la
frontière ils peuvent y peuvent l'être
mais ils ont aussi la possibilité de
faire valoir un certain nombre de droits
notamment le droit de voir leurs leurs
examens enfin le l'examen de leur
demande d'asile l'être dans un autre
pays qui offrent un meilleur accueil
voilà la france fait beaucoup d'efforts
aujourd'hui pour essayer d'améliorer les
conditions d'accueil des migrants
donc 1 1 un ressortissant ghanéen guinée
ou maliens
qui passe par par un autre pays que la
france
s'il se voit déboutée dans ce pays-là
peu tente effectivement de se faire de
faire à nouveau examiné son dossier dans
en france conformément évidemment aux
règles européennes grands qui permettent
au delà d'un an en fait de se voir le
cadre de ce gardien qui donc a passé la
nuit au poste de la police des
frontières
on le relâche et après ils cherchent
mais tout dépend des conditions dans
lesquelles il est arrivé en réalité ce
cela s'il a déjà déposé une demande
d'asile
lorsqu'il est contrôlé on le relâche
parce que sa demande d'asile doit
examiner d'accord c'est obligatoire le
droit d'asile en france est un droit
constitutionnellement garanti un
demandeur d'asile dans la mesure il
arrive en france
persécuté dans son dans le pays de rien
a priori et peuvent boire y apparaît
jenson il a pas de guerre il n'ya pas
mais il le dit bien vous savez
aujourd'hui au fond la définition avec
une les conditions de l'asile
traditionnels ne sont pas celles qui
sont à la base des migrations
aujourd'hui vous savez il y à des
systèmes qui sont complètement bloqués
en afrique ou ailleurs est donc
aujourd'hui les gens cherchent un meurt
une bouée d'oxygène
voilà une bouffée d'oxygène ailleurs que
dans leur pays en réalité c'est cela
jean yves le gallou on l'a on l'a vu un
témoin d'entrée en europe -
d'immigration en tout cas vous avez
peut-être me dire le contraire mais
des personnes en tout cas qui sont
toujours un peu exaspéré justement de ce
problème migratoire notamment un menton
qu'est-ce que vous avez alors c'était
moi d'immigration en europe je n'ai pas
les chiffres il ya eu un million cinq
cent mille qui sont rentrés il ya
quelques années sur la décision
totalement irresponsables de madame
merkel de diabo la merkel moins
d'immigration en europe
je ne sais pas j'en doute mais plus
d'immigration en france ça c'est sûr ça
c'est sûr il y avait quarante mille
demandeurs d'asile il ya dix ans il y en
a eu 160 milles cette année et on voit
très bien d'ailleurs comme l'a dit
madame je suis assez d'accord avec elle
ce n'est plus du tout de la jil
politique d'ailleurs le ghanéen qu'on
interroge il dit je viens ici parce que
je pense que cette radio que la barre
voilà il dit pas parce que je suis
persécuté politiquement ce pourquoi elle
fait le droit d'asile
donc on est en plein détournement du
droit d'asile c'est devenu une filière
d'immigration clandestine de plus est
d'autant plus qu'une fois que les idées
refusé ce qui est quand même le cas
cette année il ya 160 mille demandes
l'an dernier je crois qu'il ya eu
environ quarante mille demandes qui ont
été accordés quarante mille statues
32000 voilà merci de dire un peu moins
si je fais l'écart entre les deux
j'arrive à 100 130 mille cent vingt
mille et combien yat-il d'expulsion
combien y at il eu d'expulsion de
clandestins l'an dernier c'est 25000
25000 mais les chiffres ça veut dire
j'ai dit est en augmentation les
raccompagnements une mesure
d'éloignement seigneur 25000 quand vous
comparez à 120000 sachant qu'il ya
d'autres clandestins que les déboutés du
droit d'asile
vous voyez très bien que les gens
arrivent et qu'il reste qu'il ne reparte
pas parce que les lois ne sont pas
appliquées et que nous sommes dans une
situation qui n'est plus une situation
de migration qui est une situation
pardon de dire le mot d' invasion
migratoire puisque des gens de plus en
plus nombreux arrivent sur notre
territoire en violation de nous de nos
lois c'est ça la réalité et ils font là
aussi je peux rejoindre
les personnes avec qui je débat dans la
mesure où les gens ils font leur
shopping migratoires et pourquoi il
arrive aujourd'hui en france parce que
la france a actuellement les dispositifs
parmi les plus favorables d'europe et
comme ça se sait eh bien il arrive en
france
et quand on nous dit macron va prendre
la situation à bras le corps
bat depuis maintenant deux ans et demi
qu'il est président de la république
presque trois ans la situation s'est
considérablement dégradée et le nombre
de clandestins s'est considérablement
augmenté et voilà les fêtes
alors si on l'avait fait avec catherine
vital non parce que d'une part on n'a
pas le nombre de demandeurs d'asile de
pas de demandeurs d'asile si mes deux
sans papiers n'ont par définition ils
sont sans papiers oui mais on ne peut
pas dire qu'ils ont augmenté ou ou
dernier salut à vous donner les chiffres
mais nous ne les donnent plus d'oeufs
puis 2019 justement ce chiffre de
clandestins passion aussi ya quand même
des rapports n hésitez pas joué alors
qu'elle était star mais elles ne sont
pas reliés par l'institut montaigne
disait autour de 300 mille demandeurs
d'asile sans fatiguer de sans papiers je
vais dire va sans dire voilà trois cent
mille mais c'est parce que je considère
comme totalement sous-évalué mais c'est
ailleurs 600 soles année mais y'a pas
horriblement l'année dernière rien que
sur les demandeurs d'asile qui n'ont pas
obtenu le droit d'asile
et si on compare ce chiffre avec les
déboutés on arrive à plus de 100 milles
alors sur une seule année
et ça prend pas tous en compte donc le
chiffre de 300 milles franchement il
n'est pas sérieux d'ailleurs
effectivement ce n'est pas un hasard si
les services de monsieur castaner comme
vous l'avez justement souligné ne sont
plus les estimations sont des
statistiques est absolument voilà alors
continuez madame vittel d'autre part sur
les demandeurs d'asile déboutés qui
selon certains devrait être reconduit il
y en a certains que légalement ne peut
pas reconduire ce qu'on appelle
l'économie voilà parce qu'ils soient ils
viennent de pays en guerre c'est le cas
de en partie des gens qui viennent de
syrie quand même faut pas l'oublier mais
aussi des mineurs qui sont arrivés
isolé et non-accompagnés qu'on peut pas
reconduire puisqu'on a signé comme la
plus tôt mme tous les pays européens la
convention de 89 sur les droits de
l'enfant donc 2e catégorie qu'on ne peut
pas reconduire et donc il ya toute une
série de gens qui de toute façon les gaz
mortels ne sont pas reproductibles dans
leur pays d'origine pour des raisons
légales il social et il est expulsé
alors qu'elle est celle de la convention
de genève
ça ce sont des interprétations pourrait
tout à fait exact la convention de
genève comme la convention
internationale des droits de l'enfant
ce sont des textes très généraux ou du
parent qui a pas qui correspondent à une
situation qui était celle que
connaissent l europe et le monde il ya
40 ans 50 ans les choses ont beaucoup
changé depuis et ce qui est ce qui fait
aujourd'hui le problème c'est pas
tellement ces textes fondamentaux
c'est l'interprétation qui en est donnée
par les juges que ce soit les juges de
la cour européenne des droits de l'homme
où les juges la cour de cassation ou de
ou des tribunaux administratifs
c'est une interprétation
jurisprudentielle il ya donc une
opposition entre des décisions qui sont
prises par des gens qui ne sont pas élus
et parce que voudrait sans doute
beaucoup de français en tout cas quand
il ya des sondages où on demande aux
français est ce que vous pensez qu'il
faut arrêter ou non l'immigration
il ya généralement les deux tiers voire
davantage qui répond qu'il faut arrêter
l'immigration or qu'est-ce qui se passe
le volume d'immigration doul les
demandes d'asile ont triplé en dix ans
les demandes d'asile ont triplé en dix
ans et les entrées comprennent l'asile
où les autres modes de séjour les
demandes d'asile ou les autres modes de
séjour les titres séjour sans parler des
mineurs isolés auquel on a fait allusion
ont doublé aussi en disant qu'elle est
habilitée à une volonté populaire
d'arrêter les migrations nom et il ya
une pratique gouvernementale et
judiciaire qui consiste à la doubler ça
n'est pas la démocratie danielle babin
si l'on considère effectivement que lui
création est en hausse depuis dix ans
c'est un fait pour quelles raisons
spécifiquement alors je suis souvent
étonné de voir que le débat sur
l'immigration en france est souvent un
débat de chairlift et de deux voiles à
deux chiffres sont à la fois cet aspect
au bout et il ferait on ne peut pas
chiffrer l'être humain vous savez l'être
humain il est complexe et vous savez
tous les peuples aspirent à la liberté
tous les peuples aspirent à la
démocratie lorsqu'on considère que la
démocratie ne sied qu'à l'occident et
que en afrique quand même qui est un
continent aujourd'hui qui est hyper
peuplée et où on voit ployer sous des
ddd tyrannie des dictatures une est un
système complètement désorganisée aux
plongées d'airé économiques sociales et
politiques
je dis que là nous faisons preuve de
beaucoup d'hypocrisie en occident il
faudrait équilibrer la question de
l'immigration en europe
parce que vous savez il est très
équilibré c'est à dire la solidarité
notamment demandé que le mandat du tout
pas du tout il faut déjà poser le vrai
problème la cause des migrations déjà en
partant d'afrique
quelles sont les causes réellement alors
les alors la bnr non mais attendez vous
avez parlé le je vais je vais
m'empresser de maryse malaisie l'alizé
je voudrais plutôt que de vouloir
résoudre le problème en est je dirais
arriver enfin à l'arrivée donc les
effets il faut commencer à traiter les
causes
l'écho sans quoi c'est que les
gouvernements
aujourd'hui vous savez quand on pose la
question en france de sa diplomatie par
rapport aux pays d'afrique francophone
on vous dira la france ne fait plus
d'ingérence politique ni économique en
afrique
tout passe par l'union européenne ça
vous n'êtes pas d'accord mais ne sont
pas du tout d'accord c'est de
l'hypocrisie pure et simple
aujourd'hui l'afrique est capable
d'assumer sa destinée tant du point de
vue économique politique je dirais que
social or qu'est-ce qui se passe
l'afrique est simplement victime de
cette diplomatie fait d'hypocrisie
lorsqu'on vous dit que les africains
quittent l'afrique parce qu'il leur
manque des conditions de vie décentes
le ghanéen l'a si bien dit même mais je
vais vous dire que non le problème il
est plus loin
il est plus profond que cela nous avons
besoin de rééquilibrer les rapports
entre l'afrique et l'occident l'afrique
et la france
si l'on part du principe que en fait
tout est en afrique vous avez non les
riches ne mangea les bienvenus puisque
les demandes d'asile viennent
principalement de pays justement qui
sont qualifiés comme sur wii mais la
géorgie des pays de l'est de l'europe de
l'est est même mêlé mais en réalité je
vous assure que même les pays dits sûrs
les demandeurs d'asile venant des pays
sûrs lorsqu'on examine leur demande
d'asile easo petits nazis je vous assure
que sur 2000 tas de demandes d'asile
venant des pays sur yao la moitié qui
obtient l'asile en france
donc on fait tantôt qualifiant p2p sur
ces mecs là titre dissuasif mais en
réalité un ressortissant d'un pays sûr
je dirais d'ailleurs je pense que le
ghana le sénégal font partie des pays
sûrs effectivement mais lorsqu'on
examine un dossier au cas par cas on se
rend bien compte que les gens sont dans
une détresse tels que ça peut être
au plan politique ça peut être au plan
économique peu importe mais en tout cas
on examine les situations au cas par cas
et on se rend bien compte que là on ne
peut pas résoudre les problèmes
à l'arrivée il l'avait résoudre au
départ l'idée de l'avs et l'aï là l'un
des points 2-2 de passage de cette
immigration africaine c'est bien sûr la
libye avec tous les engagements mer que
l'on connaît dernier sondage en date en
méditerranée c'était le 13 février
dernier la des sauveteurs du navire
humanitaire espagnole ait à marie vous
le voyez sont intervenus pour aider une
embarcation en provenance de libye 150
migrants ont pu être sauvés mais 90 sont
morts avant cette intervention
ils ont été autorisés à débarquer dans
le port de messine en italie écoutez ce
statut notamment le commandant veux
préciser qu'il ya eu 90 morts lorsque
nous étions au large près de la côte de
garat bulli à l'est de tripoli laissent
tripoli
et qu'il n'y avait pas de bateau pour
les sauver heureusement les conditions
sanitaires des migrants sont bonnes pas
de cas cliniques pas de coronavirus
voilà oui ça fait sourire mais bon ça
reste aussi un problème de propagation
du virus c'est rien c'est un fait jean
yves le gall vous vouliez à la vie alors
je veux un peu leur âge et là je crois
qu'il ya effectivement on va donner les
chiffres il ya 500 millions d'habitants
en europe qui est un tout petit
continent il ya deux milliards
d'habitants en afrique qui est un très
très grand continent avec on nous l'a
dit beaucoup de richesses il faudrait
que les deux milliards qui sont dans
certaines des organisations politiques
effectivement se déverse sur l'europe
qui disparaîtra sous la masse
voilà c'est ça le projet cesser votre
classe c 'est a justifié la réalité et
l'autre problème
blood bowl il ya deux problèmes en
afrique les deux problèmes l'afrique je
le rappelle est indépendante depuis 60
ans 60 ans ça fait deux générations
voire trois générations 60 ans allen
démographie explosive quatre enfants par
femme 6 dans certains pays cette dans
certains pays c'est là qu'est le
problème
donc c est d'accord il faut pas réver fo
prend il faut agir à la base vous êtes
d'accord rude et c'est aux africains de
gérer leurs problèmes ils ont
l'indépendance depuis 60 ans on va pas
être indéfiniment responsables de ce qui
se passe chez eux
mais alors si un peut-être des chaises
louis saha ne sais pas quoi dire car je
veux dire que l'immigration
d'immigration a un effet pervers car ce
sont je pense plutôt des hommes jeunes
et dynamiques pas forcément les plus
pauvres et les plus déshérités qui
partent et qui travaille aussi dans les
milieux ils ont la santé d'oran et
douanières et donc qu'ils seraient mieux
à travailler dans les milieux de la
santé en france de la via roma c'est des
ingénieurs qui arrive
bon on a raconté beaucoup d'histoires
samantha jamais cessé d ingénieurs qui
arrive ce serait mieux qu'ils dressent
de chez vous chez eux
je vais vous dire l'asile l'asile quand
on voit quand il ya eu des réfugiés
après la seconde guerre mondiale par
exemple ou pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale quand les réfugiés s'étaient
qu'il est réfugié
c'était essentiellement des femmes des
enfants et des hommes âgés
hélas aujourd'hui qu'ils sont ce qu'on
nous présente comme des républiques et
des hommes jeunes hommes jaunes s'il
pays est en guerre ils sont là pour
défendre leurs familles devraient être
là pour défendre en famille et si le
pays n'est pas en guerre il devrait être
là pour le développer donc moi je ne
pleurniche pas sur le sort du réfugié
qui vient ici pour mieux vivre et en
laissant son pays dans la mouise
alors on aime ou on n'aime pas on avait
le cas de l'italie qui a autorisé ce
débarquement ce n'était pas le cas il y
à quelques temps encore leur matteo
salvini il reviendra bientôt pouvoir en
tout cas cette question de la migration
et les pays membres de l'union
européenne se renvoient la balle
catherine vital ouellette peut mieux
faire
alors d'une part on a des flux mixte
comme on l'a vu avec ce ghanéen ce qu'on
appelle des gens qui demandent l'asile
mais qui correspond plus nécessairement
à la définition du réfugié qui a fondé
sur la persécution ou la crainte fondée
de persécution de la convention de
genève
parce que en europe contrairement à
beaucoup de régions dans le monde
l'immigration de travail salarié est
suspendue depuis 1973 1974 selon les
pays européens
tant que l'on n'aura cette suspension de
l'immigration de travail salarié dont on
a besoin parce que beaucoup de sans
papiers travaillent dans des secteurs
extrêmement où on a besoin pour baisser
les salaires n'ont pas besoin pour
baisser les allemands paris clandestins
joie que je vous ai pas fait la parole
dans ces mêmes rêves ne fait pas je vais
donc ces gens travaillent dans des
secteurs dont on a besoin économiquement
d'ailleurs il rapporte ya un rapport de
parlementaires qui est sorti il ya
quelques semaines qui montrent que
l'immigration rapporte plus qu'elle ne
coûte
contrairement à certaines idées que ces
gens sont des consommateurs et c'est
toute une série d'éléments pour appuyer
depuis pas seulement ce rapport mais
depuis 40 ans le même propos
l'immigration économiquement rapporte
aux migrants mais surtout aux pays
d'accueil et aussi aux pays de départ ça
130 milliards de dollars envoyés dans
leur pays d'origine en 2019 je le
rappelle est temps qu'on aura une
fermeture de l'immigration de travail
salarié sauf pour les très qualifiés
dans les pays européens on aura des gens
qui tentent l'asile parce qu'ils ne
peuvent pas entrer sur le marché
du travail légal et ça c'est un problème
majeur le gouvernement s'est penché sur
cette question est absolument rien
justement les mais on n'avance pas
beaucoup parce qu'il ya un blocage
européen sur cette question compte tenu
de sauvegarde à lyon de chômeurs en
france quand même ça n'a rien à voir
comme l'ensemble des gens qui viennent
au son dans des secteurs qui ne sont pas
sollicités par les chômeurs ils
travaillent moi je prends le métro je
sais pas si vous le prenez à 6 heures du
matin parfois pour prendre un train et
donc quand je suis dans la rame à 6h du
matin il ya très très peu de blanc et
ces gens ils vont au travail ils vont
pas pour s'amuser à prendre le métro à
six heures du matin
kss kss kss que je rencontre des femmes
qui ont leur petit cabas qui vont
travailler dans les hôpitaux ou garder
des personnes âgées ou faire le ménage
dans des dans des entreprises des hommes
qui ont leur sac à dos et qui
visiblement travaille dans le bâtiment
parce qu'ils ont des chaussures avec la
panamera s qui sont pas employés
justement parce que c'est une - tous les
français qui sont pas pas nécessairement
ces licences et lion de la gauche et du
patronat on regarde dans la presse ce
week-end comme je le fais assez
régulièrement
on a beaucoup de mal à recruter même
dans des secteurs où on peut croire
qu'on est passé non je ne sais pas
rasées ça s'appelle la loi du marché on
fait venir des gens qu'on paye pas non
pour les payer moins cher c'est
absolument scandaleuse de gouache les
consciences de voter contre pas du
secteur concurrence avec des nationaux
qu'elle ne pense pas mais ça c'est long
non questions d'organisation du travail
donne que sur une série de secteurs bref
c'est une salaire et en plus vous m'avez
emmené à nouveau interrompu ce oui je
n'ai pas fait pour que vous parliez
levallois et les et d'anyama des mains
vittel de 22 cuillères agir aussi à
daniel van os quelques secondes avant de
reprendre mais non c'est à dire que il
faut savoir que l'immigration ou
l'immigration
elles sont soit voulue en tout cas la
france a organisé le système
d'immigration
lorsqu'un immigré vient en france il
peut avoir sont ils peuvent solliciter
le cas tout récemment d'un ressortissant
algérien qui sollicitent une
autorisation de travail depuis l'algérie
qui l'obtient est lui arrive en france
et qui travaillent
entre temps il est contrôlé parce qu'il
n'avait pas son passeport il est placé
en centre de rétention ensemble des
rétentions le ton qu'il justifie de ces
conditions de résidence en france mais
nous avons pu démontrer que cette
personne est parfaitement intégrée en
france
il a étudié cette personne avait études
en france depuis les années 2016 2017
elle est repartie en algérie ou en
partant de l'algérie elle a obtenu une
autorisation de travail revenus en
france en bonne et due forme messieurs
le travail en france est organisé en
tout cas des ressortissants étrangers
peuvent obtenir un titre de séjour aux
fonds en raison de leur est la
dégradation qualification et
l'intégration par le travail
donc cette façon de chaque fois
stéréotypé n'est ce pas la question de
l'immigration au tour de ceux qui
viennent parce qu'ils viennent prendre
deux des emplois réservés aux français
là aussi c'est un regard vraiment
biaisée de la question de l'immigration
resté avec nous on continue ce débat sur
l'immigration et la france qui vient
d'être épinglé par eurostat pour avoir
communiqué des chiffres qui ne
correspondent pas forcément à la réalité
on va le voir à tout de suite
[Musique]
ce qui s'est passé sur tesla s'il
voulait est assez symptomatique du reste
vous avez une déconnexion complète entre
la valeur et le prêt si vous prenez la
valorisation boursière c'est à dire on
est monté jusqu'à 165 milliards pour une
boîte qui depuis le début père en cumulé
6 milliards et demi je ne validerai pas
la valorisation actuelle qui est
complètement décorrélé des fondamentaux
en effet mais après il ira tout de même
les aspects dans cette société qui
peuvent être valorisés à une certaine
d'un certain montant au delà en tout cas
de et voitures en elle même il y à la
technologie du logiciel qui est à
l'intérieur et il ya également les
batteries qui peuvent être vendus ou la
technologie qui peuvent être vendus à
d'autres personnes ils vont 350 mille
voitures
ça veut dire que vous valoriser la
voiture entre 400 et 500 mille dollars
la voiture c'est une manipulation de
cours pur et dur
[Musique]
je
à
mais
[Musique]
il faudrait que les nations puissent se
regrouper notamment une troisième force
et c'est troisième force et l'europe
mais l'europe est incapable de faire ça
il y à une remise en cause de la
relation très privilégiée entre l'europe
et les étals et je pense qu'aujourd'hui
nous devrions développer un dialogue
france allemagne russie chic tout çà çà
çà çà çà paraît pas avancer dans le bon
sens quand même le risque pour nous
c'est de sortir de l'histoire
moi je suis convaincu que l'avenir des
relations internationales pour les
quinze ans qui y est c'est la relation
entre les etats-unis et la chine nous
hors pair si nous ne sommes pas capables
d'être le troisième pôle à ce moment là
on aura des fragilités et on sortira
l'histoire
[Musique]
pôle it mag la suite avec catherine
beetle de wenden directrice de recherche
au cnrs spécialiste des questions
migratoires experte sur une mission du
hcr jean yves le gallou ancien député
européen du front national elle danielle
babin avocate spécialiste en droit des
étrangers
après la porte de la chapelle en
novembre dernier nouvelle opération
démantèlement aux abords de paris il ya
quinze jours près de 1500 migrants du
campement d'aubervilliers ont été
évacuées encadrés par un important
dispositif policier nouvelle étape donc
après les engagements formulés par le
ministre de l'intérieur
un changement d'approché pour libérer la
zone a dit le préfet parité je
procèderai systématiquement de cette
façon là de manière à ce que les gens
qui sont dans ces situations de
désespoir soient mis à l'abri mais
également que les règles d'hygiène les
règles de sécurité et les règles de
tranquillité des habitants puissent être
ainsi parfaitement respectée 62e et
vacations elle a une particularité c'est
qu'elle se passe deux jours avant le
ce qui s'appelle la nuit de la
solidarité qui en fait le nuit où il va
y aura comptage des personnes à la rue
et deux jours avant ça veut dire que
c'est le trentin le train de ça veut
dire que il va y avoir dans les
statistiques qui vont faire foi pendant
toute l'année 2020 à peu près 1500 à
2000 personnes en moins ah ouais on est
on est dans la guerre des chiffres en
tout cas on voit jean yves le gallou le
gouvernement on nous montre en tout cas
qu'il est du côté des personnes qui sont
un peu dérangé par ses comptes mans et
qu'il agit il fait de la police au
spectacle gouvernement c'est pas le
premier à en faire tous les ministres de
l'intérieur depuis 40 ans pratiquement
en tout cas depuis la fin du
gouvernement de monsieur giscard
d'estaing ont fait de la police au
spectacle on voit d'ailleurs le résultat
quand on voit l'efficacité des mesures
gouvernementales
il ya eu une loi sur le sur l'asile qui
a été prise par le prédécesseur de
monsieur castaner au tout début du
quinquennat de monsieur macron c'était
une loi qui devait régler le problème de
l'asile le nombre des demandeurs d'asile
a quasiment doublé entre 2016 et 2019
donc ça veut dire que la loi c'est de la
poudre aux yeux alors elle a été
présentée comme restrictives les
associations immigrationnistes ont
protesté et donc le bon peuple à dire
oui le gouvernement quand même il fait
quelque chose là ce n'était pas de la
police spectacle c'était de la
législation spectacle qui n'a rien
changé dans les fêtes puisque mêmes gars
plutôt aggravé la situation salue un
effet c'est plutôt aggravé la situation
puisque simplement sur ce chiffre mais
il ya d'autres chiffres en matière
d'immigration
mais sur ces chiffres des demandeurs
d'asile il ya eu on est passé de 77
milles à 150000 à peu près entre 2016 et
2019 il ya eu soit disant une loi qui
était restrictif j'aimais vu j'ai même
vu récemment une
du monde 10 ans macron serre la vis sur
l'immigration tout ça tout ça c'est
salissant telle mesure elles ont
totalement bidon et les cds mesures
techniques et délais plus courts paradis
cachot vous savez les délais plus courts
par exemple les délais on augmente à un
moment où on augmente les délais de
rétention d'un qui peuvent passer de 30
à 45 jours par exemple le problème c'est
d'obtenir le visa de retour de la part
du pays d'origine eh bien il ya des pays
d'origine avant ils donnent un visa de
retour le 31ème jour donc évidemment le
30e jour le la personne était relâché
maintenant que ces 45 jours ben le visa
de retour il arrive le 46e jour ça ne
change pas fondamentalement les choses
ce qu'il peut changer fondamentalement
les choses c'est de dire qu'il y a les
droits individuels bien sûr mais il y a
aussi le droit des peuples à défendre
leur identité le droit des peuples à
assurer leur continuité le droit des
peuples à refuser leur invasion par des
gens venus d'ailleurs le mot invasion
cas repris l'un des rares hommes d'états
européens
le président hors ban c'est ça qu'il
faut prendre en compte
il faut refuser l'invasion et donc
changer totalement les logiciels et pas
ajuster à la marge
faire du cinéma législatif ou du cinéma
policier parce que c'est aussi politique
pour il ya des échéances présidentielles
dans deux ans est ce que le fait de se
saisir de cette question d'immigration
aujourd'hui avec des durcissements ça
fait partie aussi du du calcul politique
ce sont des faux durcissement ce sont
des apparences de durcissement s'il y
avait des durcissements écouter s'il y
avait des durcissements on n'aurait pas
tripler le nombre des demandeurs d'asile
en dix ans et on n'aurait pas doubler le
nombre d'entrées par an en dix ans il y
avait des durcissements ça se passerait
pas comme ça on avis il ya eu il ya eu
des pays qui ont su résister à
l'invasion migratoire via la hongrie ya
l'italie quand elle était quand elle
avait comme ministre de l'intérieur
matteo salvini j'espère qu'il reviendra
bientôt là oui il y avait il ya une
certaine réussite
r mais on veut pas dire ça de la france
quel prix
tels de veine des noms on a vu ces
campements de migrants qui sont démontés
les uns après les autres après grande
synthe après nantes après la porte de la
chapelle
est-ce que les rôles localisation se
passe bien ça dépend des départements
parce que très souvent ce sont les
départements qui gère notamment pour les
mineurs c'est eux qui ont la charge de
la réinstallation des personnes et donc
il ya des départements où les gens ne
dorment pas dehors puis en a où tout le
monde dedans dehors ça c'est très clair
c'est très connu les associations le
dénonce et faut dire ce qui est on est
un des rares pays européens où il ya
autant de gens parmi les personnes qui
ont vécu dans ces situations et qui sont
parfois des mineurs qui dorment dehors
donc on a un peu on est un peu champions
européens en la matière et pour
l'accueil et à la demande d'asile on est
enfin pour les années qui ont suivi 2015
en moyenne on a été entre le 13ème et
17ème pays pour l'accueil du nombre de
demandeurs d'asile au regard de notre
population donc on est très très loin
d'avoir pris l'ensemble des demandeurs
d'asile de l'europe
je rappelle que l'italie que je connais
fort bien parce que j'y enseigne à 5
million d'étrangers tandis qu'alain en
france on en a moins alors qu'on est le
premier pays historiquement
d'immigration est ce que ce en europe
c'est bien le problème l'italie on a la
même population que la france ils ont
plus d'immigrés que nous ils sont
devenus le clou troisième faye et en
birman immigrés étrangers ces deux
concepts différents vous avez bien placé
pour le savoir tout à fait novice et
c'est pareil c'est pareil même temps ils
ont plus dédié d'étrangers que deux fils
d'immigrés que nous et pourtant ils sont
ils ont démarré dans le phénomène
migratoire au milieu des années 80 donc
c'est pas l'italie n'est pas le pays le
plus restrictif quelle que soit la
politique
la charge a porté la beaucoup galles
alors il arrivé aux émirs ont la charge
hier leur de morts ni des gens arrivent
en général il n'arrive pas ici au début
ils arrivent à la drac 12 ce qu'ils
arrivent dans le sud de la calabre et
deux dépouilles et donc il y a
effectivement ils sont aux premières
loges comme la grèce faudrait en dire un
mot la grèce a également été
particulièrement frappé par tout ce qui
s'est passé depuis la crise syrienne
l'europe ne fait pas rien parce qu'un
accord qui a été signé entre l'union
européenne et la turquie avec 6
milliards d'euros qui ont été accordés à
la turquie pour qu'elle ferme ses
frontières à l'égard de l'europe la
libye a fait l'objet aussi d'un accord
européen
récemment on a élargi la zone des rites
de la mer territoriale pour permettre
aux libyens de reprendre les gens qui
sont sur ces eaux alors qu'avant
c'étaient les eaux et l'international
donc faut pas croire qu'on ne fasse rien
et le budget allemand pour coller à
l'égard voilà le budget de frontex a été
multiplié par à peu près 200 depuis sa
création
donc faut pas croire que on est dans une
politique laxiste et cetera dans les
pays européens loin de là il ya beaucoup
d'effets pervers de ce procédé on est
loin des mesures qui se durcissent mais
absolument normal phénomène en réalité
en réalité ce parce que le problème est
toujours pris du mauvais côté par le
mauvais écoutez on est en train de dire
effectivement que le budget de frontex a
été mais vraiment renforcé mais sous
quel angle sous l'angle de la sécurité
uniquement plutôt que ce bloc de la
protection et sous l'angle de la
prévention
et moi je pense que le problème m
l'accent doit être mis sur la prévention
et la protection
lorsqu'on met l'accent sur le la
sécurité cela veut dire quoi c'est à
dire qu'on va injecter de l'argent à
financer le système de sécurité libyens
notamment pour protéger pour faire la
chasse aux pacers par exemple mais entre
temps ce qui arrive en libye viennent
d'où c'est là qu'il faut voir c'est là
qu'il faut voir alors il est déjà il y
as on avait vu cette semaine à lyon
notamment une filière de passeurs la
fameuse route des alpes qu'on a vu dans
ce reportage de nadège abderrazak des
passeurs ont été condamnés à des peines
de un à cinq ans de prison souvent ce
sont d'ailleurs des clandestins
eux-mêmes qui sont déjà effectives en
laqué entretien le trafic donc il y
avait la lutte contre ces filières bête
mais je dire moi je me dis les filières
de passeurs s'alimente des espaces
économiquement et politiquement
déstructuré et dont il faut laisser la
possibilité vous savez l'aide au
développement de la france vers
l'afrique s'est elle dans non on n'en a
pas besoin en réalité questionné à la
lutte mais c'est à saint denis pour
crazy pure et simple
vous savez l'afrique a besoin d'une
prime à la démocratie plutôt que de
l'aide au développement
voilà vous savez président français a
mis sur pied cette ce que je dirai ce
petit appel de pied 1 dans les années 90
la prime à la démocratie
attendez des personnes des gouvernements
des systèmes en afrique par exemple en
ont besoin voilà de se re de ceux de se
refaire et ses squales à d'ailleurs les
africains dans leur grande majorité il
faut arrêter de financer frontex pour
faire la chasse aux pacers il faut
plutôt donner la possibilité à l'eau hr
déjà le système des nations unies pour
les réfugiés
au niveau africain de bien se structurer
de bien accueillir au niveau africain
des personnes qui peuvent fuir un pays
pour des raisons ça peut être pour des
persécutions politiques ou pour des
raisons de guerre organiser l'accueil ni
grattoir l'accueil des réfugiés
déjà au niveau africain elle est au
programme aujourd'hui de l'installation
de puits 2017 et maintenant le système
de l'installation
lorsqu'un pays africains ne peut pas
offrir 7 7 ferrer cet accueil là on peut
installer les pays enfin les les refuges
et vers d'autres sphères vers l'est vers
les pays européens ça peut être la
france peut être d'autres pays mais en
tout cas on a des possibilités
d'anticiper plutôt que de 2,2 de
renforcer la politique de sécurité il
faut plutôt renforcer une politique de
prévention et de protection parce que
des personnes qui quittent les pays pour
trouver l'asile ailleurs ce ne sont pas
des voyageurs d'agrément ce n'est pas
des gens qui sont en balade touristique
c'est des gens qui souffrent c'est des
gens qui psychologiquement socialement
sont des personnes complètement dans des
états lamentables qui ont besoin
vraiment d'être accueillis dans des
conditions humaines a l'air
baptisé juste au gouvernement d'
emmanuel macron a choisi néanmoins de
durcir les lois il ya une première loi
sur l'immigration ensuite vingt mesures
supplémentaires présentés en novembre
dernier il faut reprendre le contrôle
ainsi ce qu'avait dit edouard philippe
regarder notre volonté c'est de faire
des choix en matière d'accueil fixer des
objectifs quantitatifs ou des quotas les
deux termes ne vont en matière
d'immigration professionnelle mettre le
paquet sur l'intégration par le travail
limité les irritants qui gêne le
parcours d'intégration
par exemple en réduisant les taxes sur
les titres de séjour et en même temps
notre rôle est aussi de protéger
l'immigration familiale en luttant
contre certains détournement ou encore
de réaffirmer les exigences et des
exigences ferme et forte pour accéder à
la nationalité française
jean yves le gallou voix parmi à les
mesures un délai koskas hurler que je
retiens c'est que quand on dit qu'on va
faire des quotas sur l'immigration de
travail ça veut dire qu'on va augmenter
ce que ce que souhaite d'ailleurs
davantage qu'on va augmenter l
immigration travail rouvrir des
migrations de travail et donc il ya
toujours des migrations 1000 à peu près
mais là la volonté du gouvernement c'est
d'augmenter les chiffres de vue de fixer
dès que ça s'arrête sans papiers seront
ces célébrités contre l'autre mais lyon
doit aussi mais ça veut dire qu'on va
augmenter les titres de séjour au titre
du travail c'est ça que ça veut dire
donc c'est pas réduit à l'immigration
c'est augmenter une filière de travail
qui est assez modeste
c'est vrai mais c'est pas pour ça qu'on
va réduire la filière d'immigration
clandestine qu'on va réduire les
filières d'asile on va créer une filière
supplémentaires ça je m'adresse
supplémentaires avec des personnes
qualifiées ces salles sont légales on va
on va on va légaliser des migrations
choisis sur des clandestins c'est ça que
ça veut dire
on ne va pas réduire on va augmenter on
a parlé tout à l'heure on a parlé tout à
l'heure de frontex
le budget de frontex c'est 500 millions
d'euros pour protéger l'ensemble des
frontières de l'europe
pardon de dire c'est dérisoire c'est
même moins moins que le budget des
associations immigrationnistes dont
certaines sont subventionnés par soros
dont d'autre part l'union européenne
dont il ya déséquilibre considérable des
chiffres on a parlé des mineurs des
mineurs isolés faut savoir que les deux
tiers au minimum des mineurs isolés sont
ne sont pas mineurs ça lady diana que
gilles et autres écouter quand les
feuilles hervé léger
on en a même trouvé de 40 ans qui pour
un mineur est quand même beaucoup mais
vous savoir vous êtes là vous quelques
cas s'assurer f1 renault jusqu'à qui a
toujours pas jeudi un cas mais y'en a un
cas en cas oui mais c'est quand même
significatif
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que ça une
conséquence grave c'est qu'un certain
nombre d'enfants français qui devrait
être placé protégés par le système de
protection des mineurs
ils n'ont plus de place parce que les
départements ils croulent sous les
demandes de mineurs isolés encore une
fois dont probablement les deux tiers
sont ne sont pas mineurs et c'est une
filière est l est républicain a continué
bien bien vu un rapport écoutez moi je
n'apparais que je me bats permet d
arriver je me base sur un rapport de
trois inspections générales
ministérielles
l'inspection générale de
l'administration l'inspection générale
des affaires sociales et l'inspection
générale de la justice qui a dénoncé et
qui n'était pas fait part que tels faits
y compris par des gens du syndicat de la
magistrature s'agissant des magistrats
donc qui n'était pas suspect de
critiques excessives de l'immigration
mais aussi sur les relations entre kiev
et mineurs que le lise
et télécoms ne l'étant pas et le système
est détournée là aussi de toutes les
façons en scène lorsqu'on n'est pas mûr
et des examens qu'ils sont roms ayant
saisi les évaluations lui très profond
mais alors parmi les mesures du
gouvernement il y à ces fameux quotas
d'immigration par métier catherine est
vital de wendel
toutes ces mesures finalement également
le durcissement aux soins d'accès aux
soins médicaux très critiqués et le
durcissement du regroupement familial
les français dans leur majorité à plus
de 50% en tout cas son sont favorables
vous voyez à ces mesures même si elles
jugent à 73% la politique du
gouvernement
mauvaise en matière d'immigration est ce
que ces quotas par métiers sont qu'une
des pistes en tout cas cette immigration
choisie elle existe déjà en partie il ya
la loi sarkozy de 2006 qui visait à
rouvrir l'immigration très qualifiés
alors si on était joueur de foot de
classe internationale ou créateurs ou
etc
mais en fait on n'a pas atteint les
objectifs puisque les intermédiaires
était tellement élevé que les gens ne
montraient pas dedans en fait on a
besoin de toutes les catégories on a
besoin de gens très qualifiés
moyennement dès qu'ils vont grayling
fier on a besoin d'une immigration
légale et ça je crois que c'est ça qui
est très embarrassante mais lulu en or
mais ça n'a rien à voir
ils sont pas dans les mêmes secteurs de
main d'oeuvre également jean yves le
gall il ya des secteurs qui ont
recouvert la chaussée lyon mieux payés
ont vu voilà enfin je vous réponds ça
s'appelle la loi du marché payant au
mieux les gens et on trouvera des gens
pour occuper tous les ans il n'ya pas
d'améliorer les conditions de travail et
on trouvera des gens pour améliorer tous
les emplois évidemment en faisant venir
des gens toujours plus nombreux venus
d'ailleurs et qui acceptent
effectivement des conditions de travail
et de salaire assez médiocre eh bien on
va pas on va pas arranger les choses
non mais il ya des secteurs il ya des
gens qui sont très bien payés les
médecins dans la campagne aujourd'hui
sont payés parfois par les municipalités
on n'en trouve pas on n'en trouve pas
avec des salaires des médecins michel
besnier leur part moi comme ça l'air de
d'entrée vrai qu'on trouve pas
l'infirmier en noir on ampute un salaire
il ya des malades
et mal payé je vous la corde des
parlements france où on ne trouve pas de
médecins qui veulent travailler alors
par voulait pendre les médecins venus
des pays d'afrique gang nord est passé
l'année médias des médecins qui viennent
de roumanie de nettoyer les rues de
zurich lui de plus en plus versatiles
non non non mais si ceci parce que
course pour beaucoup ils ont ils ont
appris dans des très bonnes années et
qui sont très compétents sur le terrain
et qui vient de bali à l'apparence des
deux mais oui dans les déserts médicaux
b s'est passé dans tous ces pays et ça
qu'on donne rien il est d'accord avec
cette mesure également c'est non mais
bon écoutez vous savez les mesures ne
peut pas être d'accord des chefs c'est
toujours à l'épreuve du temps qu'on
apprécie une mesure on ne peut pas dire
d'emblée nous sommes d'accord ce n'est
pas possible parce vous savez les
réformes en les haras en 2015 et une
réforme sur d'autres des étrangers en
2018 également je pense que sur votre
plateau déjà indiqué que les mesures qui
est envisagée ne venez pas répandre
fondamentalement aux vraies questions en
réalité qui se posent dans le dos voilà
voilà donc en matière d'immigration ou
de migration
voilà aujourd'hui où nous observons bien
que il est le nombre de demandeurs
d'asile augmente les résultats sans ne
sont pas très bon contrairement à ce
qu'on peut dire un 32000 régulariser sur
plus de cent mille demandes
on ne va pas on ne va pas dire que voilà
que la france accueille je dirais
considérablement les grands gaillards
des demandes d'asile qui sont
extrêmement fortes la france ait buté
devant l'allemagne
d'ailleurs les chiffres communiqués à
l'agencé eurostat l'agencé européenne
sont ceux de l'ofpra qui m'a forcément
les bons chiffres nous est tout sauf un
depuis dix ans qui est d'ailleurs par
eurostat néanmoins le gouvernement cette
question de quotas alloués par métier et
soulevait aussi par les britanniques à
on a eu une action des migrations
puisqu'ils sont sortis de l'union
européenne sur cette question là le
gouvernement britannique qui a indiqué
ce dimanche d'ailleurs qu'il allait
privilégier maintenant depuis sa sortie
d' union européenne l'immigration de
travailleurs qualifiés donc on le voit
jean yves le gallou c'est aussi la piste
évoquée par nos voisins britanniques
oui mais je pense que ce n'est pas
seulement les médecins
il ya sûrement un manque de médecins en
france pourquoi parce qu'il ya eu une
politique de quotas tout à fait excessif
menaient d'ailleurs par le prédécesseur
si j'ose dire de monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur philippe par monsieur
juppé on a limité excessivement le
nombre d'informations de médecins et
après effectivement on fait venir des
médecins qui peuvent venir d'ailleurs ce
que je ne trouve pas un satisfaisant
non parce que ben ils ne soignent plus
leur population et ça n'est pas ça n'est
pas satisfaisant prenez les gens à
travers les pays à travers les
continents
ça correspond effectivement au projet
global de mondialisation et de
déracinement mais ce n'est globalement
pas satisfaisant formons des médecins
français je suis bien qu'il faut un peu
de temps d'ailleurs on va augmenter là
aussi le ring en choisissant même
numerus clausus formons des infirmières
peillon l'est correctement ne pille on
pas alors la voyez je peux prendre un
vocabulaire de gauche aussi parfois ne
payons pas les ressources humaines des
balkans ou des pays ou des pays
d'afrique
franchement je trouve pas ça bien on va
passer aux questions réponses à présent
est le résultat de notre sondage en
ligne
[Musique]
voilà la question sur nos réseaux
sociaux aujourd'hui était faut-il fermer
les frontières pour lutter contre
l'immigration illégale et la réponse est
oui à 73% évidemment c'est un panel de
téléspectateurs sur les réseaux sociaux
drt france uniquement on le voit cette
question en tout cas préoccupe book
toujours les français jean yves le
gallou c'est aussi votre vous auriez
voter oui moi aussi
ah oui certainement oui j'aurais dû le
faire d'ailleurs j'ai été défaillant la
leur est venue voter oui si vous voulez
je crois tout simplement pourquoi les
français n'ont pas confiance dans la
politique d'alassane 14% 74% pourquoi
parce que oui ils pensent qu'il faut
fermer les frontières et celle que comme
dirait non déjà grand c'est
effectivement la dérogation à seniors
sont des nuls comme dit renaud camus qui
n'aiment pas les chiffres
ils ouvrent les yeux et ils voient que
les frontières ne sont pas ne sont pas
fermées voilà et donc ils se disent la
politique est pas bonne puisqu'on nous
dit on va fermer les frontières on va
arrêter les frais on a quand même une
immigration qui n'est pas toujours très
bien intégrés et qui même souvent n'est
pas intégrée du tout suite voir ce qui
se passe dans les banlieues bon et donc
les gens disent il faut arrêter et et en
fait on continue alors évidemment les
gens disent il ya quelque chose qui ne
va pas bien sûr il ouvre les yeux
4 les chiffres les chips et les chiffres
mais les yeux ça permet de voir
catherine est vital de wenden utopique
de penser qu'on va pouvoir fermer les
frontières comme ça du jour au lendemain
puisque l'essentiel des flux qui entre
ce qui est assez banal
ce sont des gens qui sont qui entre pour
des raisons légales faut pas oublier que
le tiers des migrants en europe sont des
européens qui ont la liberté de
circulation de travail et
d'installations en europe sont pas
considérés comme migrants dans le
satisfait en oubliant de mal hier par le
migrant les européens à l'intérieur de
l'europe dans les statistiques et 11 mai
et n'oublions pas les européennes ils
sont étrangers la circulation si l'on me
grâce à aller pour moi dans l'essonne
sont nés dans un pays dans une politique
d'immigration de les européens ont
tendance à regarder le rapport de l'
ocde
vous verrez qu'ils sont totalement dans
les statistiques pendant les cinq villes
françaises consulté pas passer mais ça
c'est un autre sujet les mails ont
d'ailleurs en familiale c'est pas la
première source d'entrée légal en france
si leur groupe en famille la star
principe qui a été qui est
constitutionnalisée depuis 1976 donc on
ne peut pas interdire le droit de vivre
en famille qui est un droit considéré
comme fondamental le droit d'asile en a
signé la convention de genève depuis
donc on peut pas interdire aux gens qui
demandent l'asile de solliciter de
remplir leur demande même si tous ne
seront pas acceptés d'ailleurs ce qui
est tout à fait normal ensuite on a les
mineurs isolés on est obligé par la
convention sur les droits de l'enfant de
les accueillir et de l'éducation qui ont
eu le malheur et la nation il ya des
talents à peu de temps elle ya des
nageurs sont lesquels légalement on ne
peut pas fermer les frontières du jour
au lendemain c'est une idée fausse qui
est diffusée par l'extrême droite qui
est utopique les yeux de bill australie
deux sont ceux qui prônent ce genre de
d'annonce mais ça ne correspond
absolument pas au système légal que vous
connaissez aussi bien parce que je crois
que vous avez fait l'ena qui existe dans
tous les pays européens
merci ce sera le mois de la vie oui je
suis comédien qu'il faut changer
précisément nous n'avons plus le temps
malheureusement même si beaucoup nous
n'avons plus le temps merci catherine
vital de wenden merci beaucoup
danielle babin excusez moi mais on en
reparlera évidemment merci jean yves le
gallou d'avoir participé à ce débat
elle c'est la fin de deux pôles it mag
restez avec nous
[Musique]
il enseigne qu'on ne se sont pas
protégés
c'était si terrible qu'on ne pouvait pas
dormir la nuit
[Musique]
où
la falaise nous vivions heureux jusqu'à
ce que la violence soit venu frapper à
notre porte
quand ils venaient ils pouvaient choisir
une femme à leur goût puis la violer et
tuer son mari
il faisait tout